wenn ihr diesen wahlkampf beklagt wird
dass es ein kampf kreist und visionen
fehlen dann kommt einem automatisch gerd
schröder in den sinn man kann von ihm
halten was man will und sich aufregen
über seine russische nach kanzler
karriere man kann auch belächeln dass er
sich in den sozialen medien als
influenza versucht aber als kanzler war
er vielleicht die letzte regierungschef
der kämpfte und etwas riskierte und zwar
mit der agenda 2010 die vielen bürgern
etwas abverlangt aber auch für
jahrelangen aufschwung sorgte fördern
und fordern war das prinzip dass ihn
letztlich die kanzlerschaft kostete von
dem seine nachfolgerin angela merkel und
das land aber noch lange profitierten ja
aber mit diesem prinzip könnte es schon
ganz bald vorbei sein nina schenk ist
bei uns schönen guten morgen du hast die
themen des tages mitgebracht und
natürlich auch deine aufreger und das
ist auch schon so einer da sind wir
schon beim punkt ja da sind wir sogar
gestartet mit meinem größten aufreger
bzw nicht wegen dem satz ich finde den
satz richtig und wichtig von armin
laschet sondern wegen der kritik der
dafür erntet der satz hat hier ist kein
beruf das hat er ja gesagt mit blick
darauf die umverteilungs gedanken von
grünen und spd die grünen wollen ja
keine sanktionen mehr von hertz bei
hartz iv das ist aber falsch auch in
meinen augen nicht nur in den augen von
armin laschet was er sagt mit hartz4 ist
kein beruf zeigt ihr auch ein
menschenbild das armin laschet hat er
hat das menschenbild des förderns und
forderns während die grünen die menschen
ja eigentlich wollen die grünen sie ein
sozialsystem parken und das ist glaube
ich ein ganz springer punkt man lernt ja
wenn man abitur machen sagen die eltern
ja mach was aus deinem leben kümmert ich
arbeite dafür das ist ein richtiger
gedanke aber die grünen und auch die spd
haben irgendwie die vision des menschen
der ja auch eigentlich gar nicht
arbeiten will wir machen ihm vom stark
abhängig keine sanktion mehr es gibt
aber experten die ganz klar sagen
sanktionen helfen damit menschen auf dem
arbeitsmarkt auch wieder einen job
finden sanktionen helfen ja auch das
bringt ja auch antrieb und deswegen
verstehe ich armin laschet as er hartz
iv ist kein beruf hat viel sollte auch
nur eine übergangslösung sein wir müssen
stattdessen vielmehr dafür sorgen
menschen arbeitsmarkt zurück zu gliedern
und auch ich glaube an den mündigen
bürger und nicht daran dass man menschen
im sozialsystem parken sollte das
glaubst du wie dieser satz von an
laschet bei den hartz-iv-empfängern
selbst ankommt
ehrlich gesagt glaube ich dass bei den
hartz 4 empfängern die selber gar nicht
hat wir bekommen wollen und das sind ja
viele also man denkt ja immer
hartz4-empfänger selber finden das toll
natürlich finden sie das nicht toll und
der satz sagt einfach hat es kein beruf
und das ist ja auch die wahrheit ich
glaube bei den hartz 4 empfängern die
gerne die soziale hängematte nutzen und
auch die gibt ist das ist eine traurige
aber harte wahrheit bei denen kommt es
natürlich negativ an die freuen sich
natürlich wenn sie keine sanktionen mehr
kriegen sollten aber der satz ist
einfach richtig und ich glaube wir
müssen viel mehr anfangen zu schauen zum
beispiel auch was weiterbildung betrifft
was umschulungen betrifft fördern statt
fordern also man muss die menschen
fördern und fordern natürlich und ich
finde das menschenbild was grüne und spd
auch in den wahlkampf so offenbaren weil
die sind ja weit weg von gerhard
schröder der als darüber gedacht hat es
ist ja dieses menschenbild der staat
muss für den menschen sorgen der mensch
wird abhängig gemacht vom sozialsystem
und das finde ich auch grundlegend
falsch
[Musik]